se reunieron al pie del edificio
evacuado por el ataque ruso
conmocionados a por la muerte de unos 40
civiles Aquí estos ucranianos han venido
a pedir más ayuda a sus aliados
occidentales a quienes se dirigen
directamente
estamos muy agradecidos por su ayuda a
nuestro país pero necesitamos más ayuda
para proteger nuestro cielo para
proteger a nuestra gente porque muchos
de nosotros estamos muriendo
su deseo como el de su presidente
bolodimir zelenski obtener lo antes
posible armas capaces de socavar los
planes del kremlin la prioridad misiles
de tierra de alta precisión y con una
gran autonomía de unos 300 kilómetros
denominados ataque MS han sido
solicitados por Ucrania Estados Unidos
desde hace meses porque podrían
utilizarse para contraatacar con fuerza
y sobre todo lejos de las líneas rusas
exigimos el suministro de estos misiles
de largo alcance porque pueden dañar sus
aeródromos los rusos tienen muchos
misiles pero no tantos aviones por lo
tanto la forma más eficaz sería destruir
no los misiles en sí Sino cualquier cosa
capaz de lanzarlos misiles capaces según
que de cambiar la situación militar pero
por el momento Washington sigue
negándose a entregar